el presidente Luis Arce ha promulgado la
polémica ley del censo aquella por la
que Santa Cruz ha realizado un paro de
36 días y que permitirá la
redistribución de recursos económicos a
las regiones con base en los datos
censales a partir de septiembre de 2024
Y que además permitirá que se
redistribuyan los escaños parlamentarios
antes de las elecciones de 2025 durante
su discurso el presidente Arce ha
fustigado duramente a la oposición
cruceña ha señalado que Durante los días
de paro se han producido muertos heridos
y actos de racismo que no quedarán en la
impunidad por eso ha anunciado procesos
a nivel nacional e internacional para
asentar un precedente en contra de los
responsables de estos hechos el
gobernador de Santa Cruz Luis Fernando
Camacho ha respondido que lo que está
haciendo Luis Arce es Bajar una línea
represiva en contra de Santa Cruz y
además ha acusado a los dirigentes del
partido oficialista de ser los
responsables de la violencia ocurrida
Durante los días del paro Luis durante
su discurso además se ha referido a la
profunda crisis por la que atraviesa su
partido el movimiento al socialismo ha
dicho que existe gente dentro de sus
filas que busca acortar su mandato y que
quiere verlo fracasar de hecho antes de
que Arce promulgara el la ley del censo
el expresidente Evo Morales ha señalado
que el presidente está a punto de
cometer un error histórico de hecho
morales y sus seguidores acusan al
gobierno de Arce de haber traicionado al
movimiento al socialismo Al haber
aprobado esta ley porque consideran que
es una concesión a la derecha de Santa
Cruz